hello and today we're talking about the
catholic church and the abuse of
power this after the highly influential
cardinal reinhardt marx
offered his resignation to pope francis
citing
the catastrophe of sexual abuse by
church officials
meanwhile shock and grief in canada
after mass graves of indigenous children
are discovered at a former catholic run
school on to the point we ask
catholic church power and abuse of power
[Music]
well thanks very much indeed for joining
us here on to the point where my guests
in the studio
are anna joff is a professional musician
and church activist who says instead of
structural reform we need to refocus on
the actual aim of the christian faith
which says anna is eternal life
also with us is max cappa bianca a
dominican priest
and for many years church journalist he
believes that the church should
not be afraid of change and a warm
welcome to to matthias
catch from the abuse survivors
organization ekke
tish who warns that it's high time for
the church to really listen
to the voices of the victims
interesting stuff so much to talk about
thank you all three for being with me
today and i'd like to begin with you
uh father max and uh the letter of
resignation from cardinal marx to pope
uh
francis uh it was
fascinating that he used the language
that he said
a dead end had been reached in the
catholic church in germany
what do you think he meant there i
when i heard about it i was shocked by
the wording because
that end is harsh it's really not
also very encouraging and i was
wondering what
what led him to use these words and
he didn't explain it more what do you
guess
my personal opinion is you know in
germany the
catholic church started a reform
process some years ago called sunu
dalawake's
a similar path exactly and um
and they are discussing different issues
like uh
power use of power or the role of the
woman in the church
the how priests should live and
um and the discussions
come often to a point where then
it said oh this is not possible because
the
church law doesn't allow church law
doesn't allow it or the
vatican will never allow it and if we
talk in this way
we can never change anything and and so
a kind of frustration also in the people
is growing
and maybe also in the cardinal and i
think that
this is meant by that end and of course
matthias couch the uh
the the pope has rejected the
offered resignation what do you read
into that how do you
what's your understanding of what that
tells us well
first of all the language used by marx
in his statement
uh was very surprising because for the
very first time a bishop in germany
used the word i in combination with
responsibility for the abuse crisis
the fact that the pope rejected it
i think will complicate issues because
the high respect we as survivors had for
this
step of mike's to step down
um now we will focus on his role
in the past and the diocese of trio and
munich
because he also was part of the system
and i'm pretty sure we will learn about
his failures
and errors in the past and maybe he will
have to
repeat his resignation
to the pope after we learn more about
the investigation there
ananda i'd like to ask you too you're
from an initiate an initiative called
maria 1.0
what tell us a little bit about what
your organization is all about and how
you read the current situation with this
dramatic development surrounding
cardinal marks
well actually uh maria and snow
1.0 developed as a response to maria
second point 2.0 2.0
and um we think that the mother of god
doesn't um doesn't need an actualization
she doesn't need
a number it's mary and the church is the
church
and um of course we we like development
we are not against development we are
not against reform um
actually it's exactly the opposite we
think that reform is very very important
but we think that the source of it
must be a spiritual renewal and uh
you you mentioned maria 2.0 and uh
their goals as i understand it are equal
rights for women especially uh
including liturgical rights
what's what's the problem with what is a
liturgical right
every uh believer has the liturgical
right to
to celebrate the liturgy to be part of
it
and to take part in this divine worship
and there we are all equal so
um this whole idea of um equality
meaning
men and women do exactly the like the
same things
um i think this is a very um
simplifying um idea which doesn't
um it doesn't take into account what the
church actually is
it's not about equality it's about um
having eternal life in jesus and living
with jesus and i as a woman
are not less um called
my my vocation isn't less um yeah it
doesn't mean
less material i'd be interested to hear
what you have to say about well
unfortunately the church is overall a
power structure
and um you have a hierarchy
you have a highly um hierarchical
structure
of power and abuse of power
and every sexual abuse which occurred
thousands and thousands
times not only in germany but all over
the world by catholic priests and
clerics
we're also a power abuse so when we talk
about the
church and the structure of the church
and the responsibility of the bishops
and
and the pope and the cardinals then we
need to
talk about the power structure um i
don't want
to talk about church reform this is
something
the church the believers have to discuss
i
can say i was a catholic
and i was abused because i was a
catholic
but my interest is the
situation of the survivors of the
victims
and i want to make sure
as a member of the civil society that
this cannot repeat
in the future okay let's just get one
answer from and on that because i think
i i wonder how much how dismaying you
find it that the church that you are
a member of and is such an important
pillar of your of your own personal life
that has let
so many people down over such a long
period of time
it's horrible it's simply horrible
and i think i do not disagree with you i
think we all agree
that this is terrible and that we need
to be clear about it and that truth
should be in the center of investigation
but i think that the interesting thing
is that in germany we are talking
a lot about power now but actually if we
listen to what the church actually
teaches about power we learn
that according to what jesus wants from
us
he wants that power actually consists in
service
and in serving people and if the people
who
committed abuse would have heeded the
actual things jesus
preaches and the church preaches they
acted against the church they didn't act
with the church
or with the church's ideas
they acted grossly against it and so
what i'm missing in this discussion is
to take the perspective jesus took
he um he ex he changed
um the system of power because he was
crucified so now
power is not ruling
okay okay well the point well taken
let's just go back to first of all
though to cardinal marx he is as we have
seen one of the leading figures
in germany's catholic church he's a
household name indeed let's find out
a little bit more about the man and his
his mission and then we'll talk about
the pope's reaction to it all
cardinal reinhard marx is seen as a
modernizer in the catholic church
he wants more ecumenism but above all he
wants a thorough clarification of the
abuse scandal
marx has heard the victims and regrets
that he himself did not do enough to
protect them
according to a study catholic clergy in
germany have sexually abused
at least 3 67 children
since the end of world war ii the number
of unreported cases is likely much
higher
but clarification has been slow marx
believes the church is at a dead spot
and that there need to be consequences
of individual officials but also
responsibility for the institution
itself whose job is that
the past for the time before
the archbishops offer to resign does the
wrong person have to go
so cardinal marks offered to resign that
that uh offer has been
rejected as we have to understand it by
the pope now what does that
what does that mean because i think many
people had pinned their hopes on
cardinal marx as perhaps a man
for the future of the church for
galvanizing the future of the church
we don't know what the pope led to his
decision
but me i personally think that um he
would have accepted the resignation if
he
thinks that he has no moral authority
anymore
to lead his diocese and
by not accepting it he says okay
lead your flock uh take your
responsibility in this way by
staying in your job and uh
i personally it was my wish that pope
would not accept the resignation
and and i hope he will go
on on this way to to learn how to
deal with these problems because he
really developed his
himself his he he said he's now saying
things
three years ago he was not able even to
think about
for example for example one
thing he was asked three years ago did
any bishop think about to resign
after all happened and she said no but
he said it in a way no
how dare you to ask me and now he said
oh
this worked was inside him and he was
really
yeah concerned by the fact that we
should think about these things and
um and that shows that he realizes that
there is a deeper responsibility of the
bishops anna is is
cardinal marx the a man that you can
identify with
in terms of taking the church forward
into the future well this is a
complicated question
um well i'm not in the diocese of munich
so he's not
my bishop but
yes i think that um
of course every bishop can lead
the church forward i think uh it it is a
question of how they take responsibility
and i actually was disappointed by no
decisions
you're sounding just a little bit as
though you're very cautious about
it about going there do you do you
believe that uh
that the church can be is the church
willing to learn is the church willing
to become a listening organization
because so many people say it so far
hasn't been a listening organization
well i think as i am not a victim or a
survivor of any abuse
i'm not the person to ask there i do not
know if the church
is listening to those people i have the
impression that she's listening more and
more but i do not know if um this is the
truth
this is what i perceive it's uh and also
well the church is not an organization
that is
a personal it's it's strictly personal
we always have to deal with persons
with all their abilities and talents but
also
um with their lack of perspective uh we
are all weak persons so
um i think it simply depends on the
bishop
and and i i think that it was very
disappointing that he offered his
resignation instead of
leading the flock through this difficult
time and also
um we do not have the reports from uh
tria nor from munich
so um well he should wait until
those um we have those uh reports so
that he can really
take the responsibility he ought to well
we have
uh reclaims from uh survivors from
trio and also from munich and we know um
that he mishandled cases of
child sexual abuse by priests in the
past
to what extent we will learn when the
reports come out but
i think the difference i see here is
i look at the church as an organization
and from an organizational point of view
i think
the debt and is the intention of the
church to deal with the crisis by itself
especially here in germany to
investigate and to clarify things by
itself
and rejecting uh an uh external
investigation like we had this by royal
commissions in australia
as an example and
this has come to that end because we
have
more than one year now the discussion in
cologne
and the cardinal there is defending
himself
and his actions with one and another and
another
uh cardinal um
study by lawyers he hired to defend
himself
and this is not the way how this crisis
can be
clarified and investigated and it should
be
investigated from outside but the
studies were not internal
and it was two studies so two studies
actually cleared him of personal guilt
at least
yeah but i mean his lawyers
lawyers yeah and they criticized him he
paid them
and they criticized uh others
like the um bishop of hamburg and
and and other auxiliar uh bishops in
cologne
but not the cardinal bulky who paid for
the
study so he the personally let's go
somewhere else that the tensions in the
discussion are reflected let's go
now from germany to uh canada uh where
there is uh
grief and outrage this after the remains
of over 200 young boys and girls
were discovered in the grounds of a
former catholic-run residential
school for indigenous children in
british columbia
[Music]
the catholic residential school in
kamloops british columbia
was one of the largest of its kind and
was run until 1978.
it is not yet known how the children
died there
the boarding school's indigenous
children were torn from their families
in order to christianize them
according to investigations violence and
sexual abuse by staff
was commonplace
as a dad i can't imagine what it would
feel like to have my kids
taken away from me and as prime minister
i am appalled by the shameful policy
that stole indigenous children
from their communities trudeau is
demanding an apology from the catholic
church
but none has been issued to date
together with the catholic church of
canada
i would like to express my sympathy to
the people in canada
who are traumatized
why does the catholic church find it so
difficult to bear responsibility
and a distressing story a very very
distressing story and this difficult
question uh a suggestive question why
does the church
find it so difficult to bear
responsibility
i don't think that you can
talk about the church in terms of
responsibility because
it's people who fail and
especially in this case i think it's
outrageous how
this case is already even though we have
little facts is already
instrumentalized those victims are
already instrumentalized
to make
points against the church even though it
was the canadian state who actually
implemented those racial
those racist policies of um taking
children from their families not to
christianize them
to to assimilate them to um
the white population and uh
so to ask an apology well first you
should ask an apology
of the state who implemented those
racist policies
and then of course the church has to
wonder um
which how how could she let herself be
instrumentalized in such a way to help
those politics who are explicitly
against um
so many um attempts to
to actually uh value indigenous culture
what the jesuits did for example they
did so much for
uh indigenous people and to to save
their cultures so
how could the church be so compromised
with
politics and i think this is an
interesting question
it is all about politics too this is not
this is not exclusively about
the church as a spiritual organization
this is about the church as a
as an uh an organization that wields a
great deal of power
i think um returning to the debt point
uh um wording used by cardinal marx
i think uh the church has a concrete
structure
of power of organization uh
and of doctrine we should talk also
about the doctrine of the church
this historic combination has come to a
dead end
and i think it has to be
changed it has to die maybe to
to live on it has no future and the way
it worked in the past and i think this
is the moment we are living
now how does doctrine come in there i
mean doctrine clearly says that
the priest is someone who serves the
flock
so this is what the doctrine says he's
changed this doctrine
yeah i mentioned that i was abused
because i was a
catholic and we have well investigated
in australia also in germany in
uh in other royal commissions that
there is a combination between sexual
moral
morality uh power um
the whole thing of um the sacrament of
reconciliation
um the uh understanding of sinful
behavior
all this is doctrine this is not only
organization we have a combination
of of this beliefs
and uh the way how the church acts and
the
priests acted and this leads to this
catastrophe
so you can't change only um the
organization you also have to
uh talk about this so the chapter
this week when i was reading up on this
story there was one sentence that kept
coming back to me that i found quite
remarkable
and it was the observation that in
germany
the word god is disappearing
it's a contentious statement it's a
contentious assertion but
it appears possibly to be true and i
think that's a significant backdrop for
the discussion we're having here
what do you say father max
anyway what i'm i i don't agree
because uh even in berlin which is
considered as an
atheistic city i
discover the presence of god in a hidden
way
everywhere so because with my eyes of
faith
i can see these presence but
what is changing and i think that's
really important to
to that the power of the church is going
down
we the church in the past has had a
structure and influence
a power which is now lost and we have to
accept it and
but it's positive because in this way we
can focus more
on the essence of faith and it's not
about structures it's not about money
it's not about power and to go to
and considering the canadian case
i also think that's something linked to
politics the past
but i think the church should be the
first one to acknowledge
their failures and we should be the
champions
of uh acknowledging that we have
something
done something wrong and i absolutely
agree there
but excuse me i i need to disagree with
both of you because what you are
painting the image of the church is
the church you wish to have i talk about
the church i experienced
and still survivors all over the world
and i know the survival movement in
canada well because we have
to be together we have been together in
rome 2019 with cardinal marks by the way
um the church is still
fighting against the survivors when they
ask for
the truth when they ask for money when
they ask for help
so the power and the money is still
there and it's used against survivors
um not only in germany but all over the
world ask the people in poland in italy
and in spain uh so um
i understand and i highly respect
your vision of a different church for
the future
but it's not actually what we are
experiencing
right uh right now i think you uh you
you say you respect
this vision but actually you are saying
that it is
a vision but maybe it is just the church
as we experience it
and i don't think that you can
annihilate our experience
against yours i think this is not the
way we should do it because we are
um in this church together those
survivors who remained in the church are
in the church together
and i think it's very important not to
try to annihilate one perspective
against the other
they are both valuable perspectives and
they are true for themselves because
everyone experiences what he experiences
you cannot say well i experienced but
what you experience
is not your experience it's a vision um
this is not taking it
seriously and vision sorry it's the fact
for example that church loses
power this is a fact it's not a vision
and i also agree that it's a good thing
because then we can concentrate on
the gospel and i think that actually
what you are demanding
is going to develop out from this loss
of power
we're running out of time i'd like to
hear your vision in
30 seconds for the church of the future
i believe in a church of the pool for
the poor a church
that strives to do god's will in all
things
we're running out of time i think we're
gonna have to leave it there but that's
a good vision for the future thanks very
very much i had the vision to sit in
saint peter's square with the survivors
from all over the world
and the church and the pope and the
bishops listening to us
a great vision too i'm so sorry that
we've run out of
i agree totally i would be really happy
wonderful stuff we've been talking about
the future of the catholic church of the
controversial juncture in its history
thanks very much for being with us here
on to the point so if you've enjoyed the
show come back next time bye bye
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
you